the one chooses the wizard mr potter
does a wand choose a wizard's destiny or
does it just know their identity
with numerous combinations of wood and
core like rare holly or thestral hair
there are many mysteries of wandler to
explore from changing allegiances to
twin cores
here's what we know about ones and their
masters and what's still left to be
discovered
while you live the elder wand cannot
truly
be mine
ones function by their own set of laws
if all of ander taught us anything
it's that a wand must choose to give its
allegiance to a wizard
to form a strong connection normally a
witcher wizard's first wand is new
and created by a wand maker certain
wands have a natural affinity for
certain wizards dictated by core wood
length
and flexibility you could also get a
wand by winning it
or even stealing it i sense his
allegiance has changed
but it won't work for you in the same
way since you don't share that
connection
like when hermione steals bellatrix as
one to impersonate her
and struggles to use it would you mind
presenting your wand
and why should i do that elder wand is
an exception to this rule because it
lacks sentimental attachment
instead it chooses the wizard who wins
it through power
and strength wands may also be inherited
such as neville using his father's wand
and ron's hand-me-down one from his
brother charlie
but these ones are not always very
effective voldemort's wand
and mine sort of connected
ollivander uses three wand cores which
tell us about the ones strengths
weaknesses and identity unicorn hair is
used by ron
neville and draco this core is known for
having the most consistent magic
and it's less likely to turn to the dark
arts which may be why draco's wand
easily switched allegiances when harry
won it
dragon heartstring is used by hermione
and bellatrix
it's incredibly powerful and learns
quickly
but can be temperamental and easily turn
to the dark arts
illustrating the diversity of a core
which can work well for two
very different witches phoenix feather
is the rarest of the three cores
and used by both harry and voldemort
they're capable of the greatest range of
magic
but picky and hard to win and tame
harry and voldemort's cores both come
from fox
making their ones brothers if they try
to duel the ones form a connection
called priori
because of its rarity most wizards don't
even know about this connection
there are also a few cores ollivander
will not use
like temperamental villa hair found in
fleur de la cuer's wand
or the prone to darkness rugaroo hair
used by seraphina pickery there's also
basilisk corn
which has only been used by salazar
slytherin
thestral hair is used in the elder wand
though its lore is very mysterious
just like thestrals it's believed only
those who have seen someone pass away
usually traumatically can wield it
wandwood is most likely to choose
someone based on his or her
distinct personality hermione's wand is
made of vinewood
which chooses those who seek greater
purpose and surprise people with their
skill and passion
ron's hand-me-down wand was made of ash
which is devoted to its master and
shouldn't be passed on this
unwillingness is even worse with a
unicorn core
it's no surprise then that ron had so
much trouble with his
ron's second wand is made of willow
which has healing properties
and is attracted to a wizard with
insecurities
but potential harry's wand is holly a
rare wood considered protective
get behind me it often chooses owners
who are engaged in dangerous quests
it's very difficult to pair with a
phoenix feather but the combination
is incredibly powerful meanwhile
voldemort's wand is made of a rare
u-wood
which has a dark reputation of choosing
notorious wizards
and as its name suggests the
all-powerful elder wand is made of elder
and only a great wizard can wield its
full strength
i am extraordinary but the one
resists me size also matters
longer ones are dramatic and drawn to
big personalities
while smaller ones favor elegant spells
and very short warns are sometimes drawn
to people who lack something
like skill or confidence most ones are
between 9 and 14 inches long but not all
the elder wand is 15 inches illustrating
its immense power
flexibility predicts a one's willingness
to change allegiances
the more flexible the more it's willing
to bend for a new master
bellatrix's wand is described as
which is part of the reason hermione
couldn't master it draco's wand is
described as springy
and harry easily won it over this was
the one that drake came out for
but despite what we do know about warns
there's so much that we don't
ones were invented in europe and studied
for over 2 000 years
ollivander believes it would take him
more than a lifetime to understand them
it's hard to get into the mind of a wand
the one choosing the wizard could be
proof of destiny
they were fated to have that wand but
there's also reason to believe that
someone's personal identity
is what the one sense is is that why
wand may accept a new master
because it believes there's a better
match for an example of fate versus
identity we can look at lily and james
james is wanda's mahogany which is great
for transfiguration
and he eventually becomes an animagus
lily's wand is made of willow and great
for charms
her most skilled subject did the ones
help them develop their talents
or were they already destined to be good
it's possible that the ones just picked
up on their personalities and
chose according to what they might be
good at basically the ones took a gamble
it's not always clear why this is one of
the greatest mysteries of wands and begs
the question
do ones even without a wizard truly have
their own identities
we might never be able to answer all
these questions but they're undoubtedly
a part
of what makes the connection between
wizard and wand
one of the most complex things in the
entire harry potter universe
you talk about ones as if they have
feelings
what do you think about ones choosing
their masters let us know what kind of
wand shows you
in the comments don't forget to hit that
like button and subscribe to our channel
for more
thanks for watching